welcome to the quick start for cloud
storage google cloud's object store for
unstructured data such as images videos
and documents
in this video we're going to walk
through how to perform basic tasks in
cloud storage using the gsutil command
line tool
to start visit console.cloud.google.com
to open the google cloud console
this web portal lets you manage and
explore your cloud resources directly
from a browser
to get started with cloud storage you
need a google cloud project you can use
an existing project or set up a new one
next activate cloud shell by clicking
its icon to the right of the search bar
cloud shell is an online development
environment that comes pre-loaded with
helpful tools for interacting with your
cloud resources
once it launches click the maximize
button to increase the size of the cloud
shell terminal
now you'll run some commands using the
gsutil command line tool which allows
you to interact with your cloud storage
resources from command line
gsutil stands for google storage utility
now create a cloud storage bucket
buckets are the basic containers that
hold your data in cloud storage
to create a bucket run the gsutil mb
command and provide a global unique name
for your bucket
this demo uses a bucket named storage
quick start dash 777 but you must choose
your own bucket name
next upload an object into your bucket
first run the wget command to download a
kitten.png image to the cloud shell
environment then run the gsutil cb
command to copy the image from your
local cloud shell environment to your
cloud storage bucket
congratulations you've successfully
uploaded an object to your bucket
now download the object from cloud
storage back to your local cloud shell
environment using the gsutil cp command
again
you'll download the object as a file
called kitten2.png
if you run ls you can see that it was
downloaded successfully
within cloud storage buckets you can
create folders to organize your objects
with gsutil cp you can upload an object
to a specific folder in a cloud storage
bucket
this command creates a folder called
folder 1 within your bucket and uploads
the kit and image there
you can also list the contents of a
bucket or folder using the gsutil ls
command
here you can list the contents at the
top level of your bucket
the two items listed are kitten.png and
folder1
you can also list details for an
individual object using gsutil ls with
the dash l flag
here you can list details about kin.png
such as its size and date of creation
now let's explore how to manage cloud
storage permissions
run the gsutil iam ch command which
allows you to change permissions for a
given cloud storage bucket
here you specify that you want to give
all users permission to view objects
sorting the bucket
the command is successful if no error is
returned
to remove public view access to these
objects run the gsutil iam ch command
with the d flag
you may also want to give a specific
person access to your bucket
this command gives the gcp student
developer 7 at
account permission to read and write
objects to your bucket
to remove this permission run the same
gsutil iam ch command but with the d
flag
to delete an object run this gsutil rn
command to delete kin.png from the cloud
storage bucket
and finally run this command to delete
the cloud storage bucket
the dash r flag is added so that
everything inside of the bucket is
deleted as well
and that's it you're now equipped to
perform basic tasks in cloud storage
using the gsutil command line tool
while this video used cloud shell you
can also use gsutil from your local
computer
check out the gsutil getting started
guide linked in the description below to
learn how to install gsutil on your
local computer
make sure to check out the rest of our
cloud storage documentation at
cloud.google.com
storage
docs so you can learn more about how to
store and manage your data in google
cloud
[Music]